déjà trois en trois ans à la tête de la
ville de bois d'arcy pour philippe
benassaya
le maire fait un premier bilan de son
expérience il parcourt la ville avec un
bus électrique pour expliquer les
politiques qu'il a menées entre 2014 et
un moment aussi de concertation et de
critiques avec les arcisien n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation d'impôts alors qu'il
n'avait eu dans les années précédentes
c'était assez élevé donc là ça s'est
stabilisé donc donc c'est déjà une bonne
chose
il ya un gros problème de circulation
dans le quartier sur la départementale
127 qui passe donc à côté de la mairie
donc tous les soirs c'est vraiment
saturé et on a du mal à rentrer chez
nous ou écoute les gens suis pas
mécontent de se menacer son mieux on
manque de crèches
il ya une microcrèche que je pense qu'il
ya un projet d'ouverture d'une
microcrèche prochainement
mais ça ne suffira pas parce que sachant
que le temps d'attentes en fait il est
en moyenne de 2 ans à l'inscription
je pense que la priorité doit être
doit être fixée sur ce volet la création
de la police municipale construction du
gymnase colette besson ou encore la
rénovation du cosec plusieurs promesses
réalisé en 3 ans non sans difficulté
maintenant ce qui est très très
difficile
c'est la lenteur administrative on va
dire la lenteur pour monter un projet
c'est toujours très très très long il ya
énormément d accueil pour monter le
moindre projet ça c'est assez compliqué
mais ça c'est pénible pour tout dire
dernière étape pour ce minibus
électrique ce samedi 24 juin au quartier
de la trembler le matin et quartier
saint-jean l'après midi